this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation
about your life and your money i'm
christie wright author of the new book
take back your time the guilt free guide
to life balance and i'm joined today by
my good friend
fellow ramsay personality dr john
deloney and we are taking your calls
triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you have a call
about money if you have a question about
relationships of course if you have a
question about starting a business you
all know i love talking about that we
are just a week out of our business
boutique event that we had last week
which was awesome john deloney
rocked it on stage was that so fun for
you by the way that was the most fun man
they're a great crowd incredible crowd
yeah okay so you can tell me the
psychology of this but here's what's
fascinating about that specific audience
because it is
99 women
99.8 but yeah okay thank you uh there is
something about the
safety of that they feel very safe to be
more expressive they laugh they have so
much fun set that up because
i went to that event early okay i heard
about this quote-unquote vibe are you
are you going to tell the story of what
what happened backstage yes um i was
scouting it out because i don't normally
talk to that crew and
um although on my show it's that's
that's the the demographic but
i'm usually speaking to business owners
and and rough and tumble folks and so i
went into that vibe and what you created
was a room of 14 or 1500
terrified i'm not here by myself
and you systematically
interjected safety you interjected hey
you're gonna have to just let that go
because that's not how we're gonna roll
in here and then yeah i roll up and i
just walked backstage and
there was like
dancing going on and i thought what is
happening this is if i have to dance
tomorrow in spandex and heal i'm not
gonna be able to do this
and anyway but what you did though and
that's so strategic was you made
everybody say dude you gotta put all of
your am i standing right am i the right
am i the right fit or the right that's
all got to go because we're about to
dance we're recording the whole thing
right it was awesome yeah well it was it
was really cool there's a there's a
method to my madness people may not see
it first glance but we had a you know
there's a girl on our woman on our team
that is an nfl cheerleader and um she
choreographed this dance because it's a
trend on on instagram reels and tick
tock to to make up dances and dance to
it and it wasn't about the dance you
know that right like it wasn't about the
dance at all it was about she's gonna
come out she does this dance they all
think they're observing they all think
we're being entertained by this
professional dancer
and then courtney turns to them and says
you're going to do that and they're like
no i'm not right like they immediately
think no i'm not i can't i'm not a
dancer these are all the excuses which
is basically a an analogy for life and
business i can i can i can't they're
different
i'm not smart enough not business minded
don't have a business background and
then they break it down into steps
dance steps
four counts break it down step by step
they do it again and again and again and
before you know it that whole crowd of
almost 2 000 women are doing the dance
and it was about what you can do
when you get outside your comfort zone
what you can do when you break something
down into steps how you you thought 20
minutes ago you couldn't do that now
you're doing it that's the message of it
and there's also a few and by the way
you're gonna have fun while i'm teaching
you this message there was a few
brave souls who went first yeah that
inspired everybody yeah because
everyone's looking around and there's a
few
rock stars who may have been there a few
times that thought uh here we go i'm all
in right and they made it okay for
everybody else yeah and that just
reminded me when i went home like man
you got hard stuff in your neighborhood
and your community go first just go
first man yeah awesome it was a lot of
fun well you did such a great job and i
know your your talk really connected
with people there's such a
power in digging into the issues behind
the issues and you guys uh experience
this when you watch the ramsey show a
lot of times you call in and it might
just be a money question like how much
am i supposed to save it might be you
know kind of surface level in that sense
and we'll give you the practical
financial steps you can take to get to
where you want to be and get out of debt
and build wealth or it might be a deeper
issue i can't tell you how many times
i've you know we've taken calls on the
show and it's like this is actually not
a money call at all it's not a money
it's not a money question it's a
relationship question or it's a you know
some other type of question so if you
have a call for dr john deloney or
myself we are here for you all day today
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're gonna kick this off and go to
indianapolis with rebecca hey rebecca
how are you
good how are you good how can john and i
help today can you hear me yeah yeah
you're great what's going on
um so i graduated in 2019 was a hundred
thousand dollars in debt 36 of that was
my name and the rest was in my destiny
as a consolidated parent plus one um and
then he wants me to pay it back but i'm
not sure what to do here because when i
went to college i actually had a full
ride to one school but my parents wanted
me to go to the same school that they
did um i didn't have money for school
and my dad just said we'd figure it out
with loans and that he would sign all
the paperwork and do all the details and
he would just call me every semester to
fill out the paperwork and get it signed
and we would figure out later how to pay
it back he said initially that i would
pay for textbooks and tuition and that
he would take care of the grooming
whether that was the dorm or renting an
apartment
but you know i found out later that he
used the rents um to pay for the
apartment with the parent plus ones so
when i graduated he said that i'd pay
two thirds of the 73 000 parent plus
loan but now he's changing the turn to
half and half and now it's kind of just
we'll both work towards it until we get
it paid off but he hasn't paid a penny
throughout this whole entire
interest rate deferment and i've been
kicking my butt off to get my own loans
paid off so good for you
so you you guys fell prey to
the three worst words in the english
language which is figured out or four
we'll figure it out
um which is mean let's just punt this
hard decision way down the road and it
just gets more complex and more messy
the further along we go
um
i
i'm torn on this christy so hop in here
i part of me says
your original agreement was
you got into a school mom and dad say we
don't want you to go there once you go
to our school we'll cover it we'll take
care of it we'll figure it out in the
road but we're gonna take care of this
and then you found out take care of it
man they took out a loan in your name
and now you're gonna be on the hook for
it
um the other part of me says
i mean
you're i mean your name's on the loan at
the end of the day you're gonna lose
your dad over this deal and you may end
up having to pay this back anyway
um so my off top my head christy i'd
love to hear what you say my off top my
head i'd love you guys to sit down you
sit down with a spreadsheet or a piece
of paper and a pen
across the table from your dad and said
the days of we'll just figure it out are
over here is the dollar amount that i
slash we owe
here's what you told me
and we need to come away from this with
a plan and we're both going to sign this
piece of paper and this is going to be
hard for you but you are having to be
the adult because you're being dragged
around by a child masquerading as an
adult does that make sense
yeah well so the 36 000 alone is just in
my name and then he has 73 000 that is
just his name is that 73 000 okay just
in the parent plus you're right so is
that 73 was it school expenses only
or did he use that for other things
i am not sure so when i calculated my
room and board and tuition and
everything there's an extra 25 000 that
i can't account for and i'm not sure
what it's for and he doesn't like to
talk about it yeah there's a lot of
unknowns here rebecca the the agreement
up front was unknown the agreement now
is unknown it's a moving target you feel
like you're not gonna be able to hit the
target and you can't because it's moving
i completely agree with john you need to
sit down have a conversation come up
with a new agreement you both agree on
and then whatever that is even if it's
that you pay all of it you'll feel peace
just knowing what you're working toward
here because right now it's a moving
target sit down and have a conversation
nail down the terms and i think you'll
feel better whatever that is
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
i'm kristy wright joining me today is my
good friend dr john deloney and we are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five just before the
break we were talking about how a lot of
the calls that we get on the ramsay show
come in as a money call or a money
decision and often it's it's really
something more than that we peel away
the layers and it's either a
relationship question or a communication
question something else going on and i
think the the call that we were just
talking to you rebecca in indianapolis
even before the break was was an example
of that because i've seen this too john
ian you could apply this to anything in
life you could apply to business or
whatever it's like well we didn't really
have a clear
agreement up front or we didn't really
have a clear plan up front and then we
both feel like we've missed the mark on
the plan but it's because there was no
plan right and then people are
hurt there's actual financial financial
consequences and uh and man that's such
an example of that because now it's this
ambiguous wolf figured out and then it's
not getting figured out
and then dad's gonna like so in that
last call um there was about a hundred
thousand dollars of of student loans 75
about 70 grand that was a was a parent
bus loan 30 grand of it was
um her student loans
and at the beginning dad said hey you
know what i'm gonna take care of this
we'll help you out here
and then three four five years later
it's
all right well you went to college and
we got you through it now you're gonna
pay the rest of this back and then this
young woman who's graduating saying whoa
i feel like the terms were switched oh
and by the way i did the math and
there's 25 000 or so extra dollars here
and that's something christy that
happens a lot as people get these
student loans
they get big checks that may cover all
their tuition all their own board and
there's an extra four five seven ten
twenty five thousand dollars left
it takes a special level of discipline
to have that much money and not spend it
on
i need a house repair or a car repair i
remember i had a check like that and my
transmission fell out and i just used
student loan to pay for that and i
didn't think about the fact that it's
gonna i'm gonna pay it 18 times for that
transmission right and so don't ever go
into a financial arrangement with
anybody without sitting down having the
hard conversation up front because my
promise is that a hard conversation
becomes way harder later and the
relationship is the casualty on the back
end so in that in that example with
rebecca so you were saying you know so
she was saying just her name is on
around thirty thousand something like
that and then her just her dad's name is
on this other part so um
legally she can walk away see okay dude
i'm paying my thirty six thousand i'm
out yeah and then what he's gonna say is
my ungrateful right daughter whatever
right but but don't you think that
there's a there's a um it's reasonable
to say if she's going to pay part of the
parent plus to only pay the part that
she can account for absolutely
that she can't account for i didn't use
this i don't know what you put on it but
i'm not paying for this mysterious 25
000. and that i didn't use that's the
problem is now you're waiting and now
what dad's going to say is
are you telling me that i ripped my
daughter off 25 you call me a liar
calling me a cheat like well you know
at that point speak to me from from your
perspective at that point isn't that a
boundaries issue of like i'm going to
cover my basis and do what i said i want
to do which is my boundaries issue you
that all that manipulation is on you if
you don't have boundaries
you will at some point
and they will either be imposed on you
or they will be built out of
self-defense self-preservation not out
of mutual
out of i get to do this it becomes i
have to do this and you never want to
build boundaries that if i have to
because that's always protecting
yourself from someone that you should be
in close relationship like your dad
right that'll that'll preach john you're
going to have boundaries regardless
i get to from a healthy perspective we
all agree on or i have to out of
self-preservation i can have boundaries
about what i eat every day or at some
point i'll be in a hospital bed and the
physician will decide
they will be imposed on me i can treat
my wife this way this way or i will get
a boundary you will not have it
i will get papers right so
you will get boundaries man what you
want to do is set them as early as
possible and towards what you want not
what you have to respond to good
man that's really good that's powerful
all right we are taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're gonna go to knoxville
tennessee with jesse hey jesse how are
you
pretty good how are you guys good what's
going on
well um my wife and i just moved to
knoxville a couple days ago
a few weeks ago we previewed the
apartment we would be moving into and it
looked immaculate and on move-in day it
was an absolute mess i mean maintenance
was still pulling somebody else's stuff
out
um it was a wreck
um i talked to the manager of the place
and uh
and basically said fix it and she put us
in the townhome on the property which is
awesome but the townhome still has a
whole host of issues uh and i don't
really know how to approach it
um
okay when you said you toured it it was
immaculate you toured like the the model
i'm guessing
okay
and then this one is the real one which
has people stuff in it how long is your
lease jesse uh 13 months
so you're in this one for a minute um i
i know that the these tenant laws are
sometimes um
state specific uh oftentimes city
specific i can tell you an experience i
had in texas where my wife and i moved
into our first apartment it was a
disaster there was bugs everywhere it
was a wreck it wasn't taken care of and
ultimately
they said go get a lawyer and
they called my bluff
and it would have cost me x amount of
dollars to fight this thing and get and
drag it out and we only had six months
left and so ultimately we wrote it out
and then left
but really you've got a legal obligation
what i would recommend is that you send
stuff in writing because they do have
some legal responsibilities if you write
down here the things that are not
finished then you can begin to build a
case so if this is a pattern of behavior
if the
things are messy turns into things that
are unsafe or unsanitary you will have a
pattern of in writing
um
not just hey i called over on this day
and if you did call document that phone
call but just open up a file and this is
super annoying and i'll tell you this
for you and your spouse um
this can be a thing you'll do together
that brings you closer together or this
can become a fist fight that divides you
don't let the second happen be
intentional about it and send registered
letters send emails with read receipts
on them and if you do have a
conversation make sure you document that
in a special journal there and so if it
does get messy or if you do decide you
know what i'm not paying this for
another 11 months or 10 months um you
can call an attorney and see if they can
get you out of that lease
yeah i think the one the one piece of
this that is encouraging to me in the in
the context of your story and your
question jesse is that they
seem somewhat like they're willing to
make it right are they are they like the
fact that they put you in a town home
and they're trying to fix it are they
trying are they trying or are they just
kind of like yeah this is it deal with
it
i mean
it's hard to tell because we moved in on
thursday and then friday was the first
day where we really had a good look at
the town home but all of our stuff was
already here
we've tested out some of the appliances
and they only kind of work um
they were closed on the weekend
otherwise i would have recorded a bunch
of stuff and we just got the last of our
stuff from our old place today that took
most of the day
so
i mean aside from me saying fix it or
i'm going to take you to court and then
for putting some town home they really
haven't done it again they swapped out
one uh electrical socket
you know what
they swapped that one out
gotcha and it may be something that you
ask them in writing obviously if i go
ahead and fix these things can i deduct
the cost of these from my rent and if
it's a matter of i need to order a new
dishwasher i need to change these plugs
out et cetera um we can deduct these out
from the ramp but ultimately it's going
to be on you to keep
immaculate records communicate in
writing and don't let this steal your
character don't stoop down to their
level don't act like a an immature brat
um continue to be professional and
respectable don't make big threats i'm
gonna do
take care of your business and if they
don't take care of their professional
responsibility what they agree to in the
lease then you go about your options
which are really i mean getting a lawyer
yeah and i think it it stinks because in
situations like this jesse it's one of
the things where you just have to figure
out
which is the which version of hard do
you want to deal with do you want the
version of hard living in a place that
the appliances kind of work or the
version of hardware you're trying to
take an apartment complex to court and
the legal side both are hard yeah you
just choose which one both have a cost
you just choose which which costs that
you want to take and i'm sorry you're in
this position no one likes to feel
misled and um and i'm just sorry yeah
that really stinks i do think that if
you continue to talk to them given your
options um i would try to get as much
leverage as you can while maintaining
good relationships just because people
are gonna respond better if you're nice
in the process just like john said don't
let it chip away at your character where
you turn into a jerk
you don't want to be a jerk and it's not
going to get great results in being a
jerk so how can you protect yourself and
move forward
and um
in the best way possible with the
options you've got i hope this helps and
good luck to you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
i'm christy wright dr john deloney and i
are hosting the ramsay show today for
you and we're taking your calls triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and
with us on the debt free stage are don
and joanne hey guys welcome hi
so i'm guessing this is good news for
you you are on our debt-free stage that
can only mean one thing you are
debt-free yep we did it congratulations
y'all okay how much debt did you pay off
uh over the last 20 years it's been
quite a bit since we got started and
married and everything but all right we
really buckled down the last five years
and paid off five hundred thousand wow
whoa okay where do you guys live we live
in kansas city area liberty
okay awesome okay so tell me okay let's
you want to focus on the five years or
you want to focus on the full picture of
the 20 years you tell me i can tell you
a little bit of the full story but
past five years we've buckled down but
um we've been married about 34 years and
started out with a little bit of nothing
you know like most people do my wife
stayed home with our three boys and i
worked a lot of hours
to kind of make ends meet you know and
she babysat and
through the years i've kind of done the
dave ramsey thing
pretty faithfully and we didn't really
spend much on vehicles and just got by
you know and
tried to make it better for our kids but
the last five years i was actually
diagnosed with parkinson's when i was 48
so we decided to buckle down and get the
house paid off and wow and uh make it
make it easier in case i got sick and
couldn't couldn't keep working so wow so
you paid off the house and everything
this is everything wow
everything y'all are amazing would have
been a little bit faster but we upgraded
our boat and okay we really enjoy that
so yeah
got to do what you got to do
what's your household income during this
time um in the past five years we went
from 150 to about 250. wow okay what's
that jump tell us that story um i
changed jobs i work for ford motor
company um on assembly line actually and
work a lot of hours there and my wife i
have my own tax and uh accounting
practice where dave ramsey elp provides
awesome my two sons three of them are
here two of them are work for me or my
partners yeah so it's a family business
and uh
so our income is increased a little bit
so that's amazing what a story you guys
have had especially over the last five
years of just the motivation to do this
the focus and intensity tell me a little
bit about this the specifically the last
five years of buckling down or saying
we're going to pay it all off
so was that 500 000 was that all just
the house or was there other stuff in
there um 275 was a house and like i said
we upgraded a boat yeah which
pretty good size boat yeah you really
upgraded we saw that picture
dave always says boats are a terrible
investment but we kind of bought it the
right time and then covet hit and it's
actually worth more than we paid for it
so
okay so my boat is uh fits about two
people in this camouflage there's holes
in it it is not that boat oh godly
that's incredible look at that that's
where we spend most of our time
wow beautiful all right so tell me what
in the last five years especially when
you guys got really focused and intense
like we're gonna pay off the house in
the midst of upgrading the boat and all
this that stuff
what was the uh what what kept you on
track what what you know what did that
look like in your marriage in a
practical way
i probably was the least
he was pushing me all our marriage and
i had he'll tell you our mentor was my
dad okay and i always i shouldn't say
this because he's probably going to hear
it but i swore i wouldn't marry anybody
like my dad because he was so tight with
his money
and then
[Music]
same name too yeah same name that's
amazing and my dad met him and turned
him into
himself
don thought don was the best choice ever
so and i was the spender and but the
last five years i think i probably cut
back and i agreed to
you know help out a lot more he's worked
really really hard and
i kind of said okay let's do this take
us back to that
that i mean your stomach
falls through the floor your heart stops
beating when they say hey this is this
is your diagnosis this is parkinson's um
and then you have to sit down and tell
your wife you got to tell your family
like take me back to that moment uh it's
pretty scary but we both kind of
embraced it and i'm doing doing fine the
last five years so
um like i said we paid that 275 on the
house we had a 15-year loan on it and
paid it off in
probably eight years or so wow so we got
the house out of the way and then the
boat was a little bit and cash flowed
our new car recently so just
just kind of buckle down and work a lot
of extra hours over time and knock it
out wow y'all are amazing the dedication
is in this
face of that diagnosis and the the fear
and all that the fact that you guys are
buckling down and doing that is
incredible who were your biggest
cheerleaders on this journey especially
this last bit well like joanne said my
father-in-law was probably the biggest
influence of course our kids you know
they've had to
suffer a little bit through the through
the years i'm not having much but
they're we're here on a trip from
kansas city this whole week and we're
kind of treating them to this deal too
to
give them the little bit of fun that
would we kind of cut out on when we were
younger you know don i'm looking at them
i don't see a lot of suffering over
there
you're missing there uh there's 23 year
olds over there in the stroller sleeping
so those are our grandkids
awesome that's awesome all right so for
someone listening right now and they are
feeling paying off their house feels
impossible and they've got health things
that they're struggling with and they
just feel down and discouraged speak to
them for a second what is what is the
key that gave you guys hope kept you
motivated kept you connected to each
other talk a little bit about how you
stuck with it even though it's hard um
most people say the budget was the
biggest key to keep them on track um i
tried to do that like she said she was a
bigger bigger spender so she would tell
me well i know what i'm spending i don't
really you know need a budget but
i think the biggest thing is just to
stay focused and not
worry about what other people have um
like i've sent a few pictures of
vehicles that i drive and drove a 20
year old car for quite a few years and
now we can kind of upgrade and get some
yeah nicer vehicles john what would you
tell somebody who just whether they got
laid off whether they were having
relationship issues they lost somebody
in the last couple years which we all
know somebody who's passed away what
would you tell somebody who's wrestling
with really hard news
um
what's their next step
like i said just have faith and and
keep your head down and buckle down and
anything can be anything's possible i've
actually got a guy that i work with at
ford um he's under 30 and i kind of
influenced him a little bit five years
ago and he's actually paid his house off
already wow
anybody anybody can do it and his wife
stays home a lot too so that's
incredible that's it for you man y'all
are amazing and i'm sure that's just one
example of the people that you've
inspired and uh right now you're
inspiring millions more with your story
so thank you for sharing that and thank
you for just uh yeah the testimony of
that hard work all right y'all we have
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
because that is definitely the next
stage in your journey and you're already
on it with paying off the house which is
incredible and we've got a copy of the
total money makeover you can give that
as a gift to a friend pay it forward
maybe get somebody kick-started on their
journey you want to get kyle and andrew
and cody up there yeah you want to get
the kids up there get them up there
that'd be awesome
all right
we have got don and
everybody with kyle andrew and cody
y'all look so good from kansas city paid
off 500 000 including the house
over 20 years but really buckled down
the last five years making 150 000 to
250 000. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
especially in the face of that diagnosis
and that adversity and feeling you know
when you get some news like that i'm
sure you just want to get in the fetal
position and just give up and they did
the exact opposite yeah it's it's it's
hard to think of any sort of light at
the end of a tunnel when you get a
diagnosis like that that you know
come two months come two years come 20
years things are going to be different
and really in my experience i've seen
two really different approaches and it
tends to be one or the other
i just throw my hands up and say this is
what this is or you see a group of
people rally around one another you've
got in-laws and a incredible wife
support a wife and say let's just go
ahead and get this done it's kind of
like we're talking about earlier the
boundaries boundaries just got imposed
and they can lean in and say all right
this is common
let's have no payments when it gets here
and by the way let's have as much fun as
possible let's make sure that boat is
real nice
and we're gonna spend a lot of time out
on the water let's not sacrifice both
but let's be intentional otherwise this
thing's coming it's some shape at some
point it's coming for us let's plan as
far ahead as we can good for you guys
yeah amazing amazing too because they
buckled down this last five years but
that was built on 20 years of following
the plan so it was that much
easier to implement these strategies
when they'd already been doing them they
just did them with more intensity and i
love that the free spirit spender is now
an account that makes my heart feel good
she's my kind of accountant i love it
so good all right y'all we'll be back
before you know it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
my good friend and fellow ramsay
personality dr john deloney and we are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and we're going to go
to harrisburg pennsylvania with evan hey
evan how are you
dude how are you guys good what's going
on
um so yeah i just had a question um
my wife and i um
she's 36 i'm 34.
we have a one-year-old i left my job
when she was born to be a stay-at-home
dad
um so right now we're in um baby step
like five
slash six where we started saving for
for her for college
um and we have a fully funded emergency
fund
um but we're also uh have savings on top
of that and i'm just wondering what to
do
with that money
should we front load
or 529 a little bit more should we just
focus on the
mortgage and get that paid off or what
will your suggestions be there yeah the
interesting thing about baby steps four
five and six is that they're all
happening at the same time in most cases
um sometimes they won't if someone
doesn't have kids but in your case you
do remember um recently dave was talking
about doing the math of what his
uh what the 529s would be when his kids
went to college backing out of that and
just front loading them and then just
leaving him alone so that's always an
option for you if you just want to put
more in there and let it grow to the
amount that that you would need
that's an option and then yeah typically
what people do is they just buckle down
and with that excess above and beyond
their budget that they you know they're
enjoying some and and you know you
should enjoy some evan but above and
beyond that you you pay off the house
early and you know we just had a family
on stage that that just paid off their
house um as an example that we're seeing
that more and more now with people that
have been living the baby steps
principles
for years and it's starting to to catch
up and pay off so yeah it would really
be other than front loading that college
fund which you could do be paying off
the house early and then you'd have no
payments yeah evan i tell you what i'm
doing in my house i got two young ones
and i am um i am making a calculated
gamble that higher ed will look
different in 10 years and 15 years after
being in it for 20 years it's gonna look
different and so i am
saving for college appropriately but i'm
i'm taking any extra money and paying my
house off that feels like more like a
more
um present liability to me than what the
cost of higher ed might look like in x
number of years let's let's just stay
here for a second evan if you've got a
second let's just camp here for a second
and talk about this this issue with
college savings because i know that
that's something that a lot of people
fear is exactly what you just said and
they think i'm putting all this money in
this account and it's going to look
different what if it's not enough what
if it's too much so what what what are
your thoughts on that especially you
know with your background being in
higher ed what's the best route to kind
of go okay we're going to follow the
baby steps and at the same time know
that it probably will change the way
they're structured right now is any sort
of education or post-secondary education
you can use it for and so if i wanted to
go back and get some more counseling
classes or my wife wanted to go get a
fill in the blank certificate or just
want to do a mid-life career change
which i've done just now um
that five plan will pay for that right
and isn't it something where if your
child gets scholarships that you can
then
there's a lot of yeah he wants to yeah
so all that to say is it's it's a great
retirement i mean it's a great savings
tool and for those especially for those
of us who man if you look over and
you've got a pile of money in account
that's gonna be hard to just let it sit
there and grow over this of course the
time at the same time um
i personally and again
every teacher's owned on this one
because you're doing four five and six
together but i'm gonna pay my house off
which is a present debt that i stare at
every month that drives me crazy
versus what this thing may be yeah the
next number of years yeah yeah evan i
hope that helps and you make such a good
point too because you've got that you've
got the interest on your mortgage right
now that you can knock that out and and
you know get not only get it paid off
earlier but then you have no payments at
all you can do whatever you want to um
but i love that reminder because it
probably will look different and and you
know what the fact that you're asking
that question evan shows me that you
have a lot of margin yeah because if you
did not have that margin and weren't
living on a budget you would not be
asking that question so well done you're
doing awesome all right let's go to leah
and lima ohio hey leah how are you
i'm going are you good what's going
on um
my husband and i we are 28 and we are
married uh 11 years now
um
we got two kids who are both in school
we have zero debt we have a
debt-free trucking company
we have fully funded emergency fund
and
we are
debating on opening up a restaurant
all right so what's your question for me
hooray on all counts yeah first of all
way to go you're doing awesome so let's
start there if you sell tacos and or
burritos you'll make a billion dollars
what's next
no you'd be sitting on the toilet
okay so yeah what can we do what can we
do to help
well
there is a
big huge building which the location
would absolutely be perfect because
it's literally right off of the
interstate
there's plenty of parking especially for
truck drivers
and this building has like
a section in the front which could be
the restaurant part the kitchen is in
the middle
there's like a little tiny bakery type
thing on the side with the drive-through
window
and on the other side of the kitchen is
a huge like hall
like would be perfect for
like wedding venues or wedding
receptions or birthday parties or
whatever oh leah you're already in love
leah has got the vision leah is already
in love oh no and then like in the very
back there is like this little office
and it would be like perfect for the
trucking company
like there's like three things right
there in a row don't do it i don't know
if we should do it or not
if you've got the cash do it tomorrow if
you don't don't do it
okay let's let's start with that part of
it do you have do you have the money to
do this
the savings to cash right now
our trucking company would be able to
fund it
in cash okay and we have the deposit and
the first month like lease
payment
upfront in cash right now
yeah yeah okay so you you've got
something to work with which is great
here's here's a couple things that i
would encourage you to do
number one i would encourage you to take
that big vision that you have and i see
it you can see it you can see the people
they're getting their coffee you've got
the office like you can see it leah i
hear it in your voice you can see it
what i'm gonna need you to do is back
out of that idea
to the
babiest version of that idea you can
think of is it just the front space is
it just the tacos is it just the office
like what is the
minimum
idea that we could start with to prove
this concept where is it just a build
out of just the front and you're going
to serve some baked goods and you're
going to prove that truckers are going
to stop at this place and get their okay
i want the baby version that's going to
be the lowest cost because it's the
lowest risk while you prove the concept
get some more money in the door to fuel
fund all that the expansion of it to
then the second part and the third part
and so on i got a head tilt to the
wedding venue because i'm not having my
wedding where truckers are now you just
told me it's a it's a restaurant wedding
venue truck driver hangout and bakery
stop meets your dream wedding i don't
see that that could be a reality show
well yeah maybe i should have the vision
but let's start with what you know will
work which is possibly a restaurant a
quick serve uh food service off the
interstate for your target market which
happens to be the trucking company that
you're already working
so i want you to definitely come up with
your baby version idea where you can
prove this part two you need a you need
a real business plan for this
what stages are you going to do what
things how much is each stage going to
cost how are you going to operate it who
all the details that are not as fun for
visionaries like you and me but they
need to happen so think of of the
staffing and all of that information um
and then i want you to think through uh
even the record-keeping piece of this
because when you said the trucking
company's going to fund it i just want
to make sure that you know when
entrepreneurs get into things sometimes
that money can get mixed and it becomes
a nightmare for taxes and record-keeping
so just make sure part of your business
plan is getting all of your your
accounting in in order for those the
expenses of this christy you work with
business owners all the time can i tell
you my first big head tell me if i'm
crazy
don't
put a penny down on a lease
until you have
gotten a contract or two in there to
tell you how much converting a kitchen
and building it and all that because
that build out may be
six seven hundred thousand dollars and
if you know the cash to do it don't do
it well and i'm thinking too like just
set up literally a taco stand in the
front with no commitment no least
nothing prove the concept
before you make a commitment that's the
idea weary of the word perfect
we do that in relationships and
businesses it's never
[Music]
perfect oh that's a good note to end on
all right i want to thank producer james
childs associate producer kelly daniel
my co-host dr john deloney and you
america this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright author of the
new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance and i'm
joined by my good friend dr john deloney
and we are taking your calls triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you have a question about money if
you have a question about relationships
maybe you need some advice you're at a
fork in the road having to make a
decision you're not sure which decision
is right and just want to bounce your
ideas off of someone else we're here
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and we're gonna kick off this hour
by going to orlando florida with holly
hey holly how are you
hi i'm great i'm so excited how are you
doing today good we're excited to talk
to you what's going on
good good thank you so much um
i
i am a single mother i'm 40 years old
and i have my little miracle baby
two-year-old daughter
and i
am trying to determine right now whether
or not i should sell my home
to take advantage of this market and
perhaps move in locally with my mother
for a year or two
even though i know in my heart that
probably is not the smartest move it
might be the best and financial decision
um
to help secure my future um
and i just wanted your advice you know
just kind of wanted to bounce a couple
ideas off of you and see why it might
make sense and might not
yeah well well i'm so glad you called
first of all um i'll
i'll tell you my my gut response and
then i want
john to talk about this because i'm sure
from the relationship aspect he is much
wiser than me i can only speak from my
experience and that is that um
if i want to have a relationship with my
mother i should not live with her and i
love my mother
love her love her living in a different
house than me
and so for me
what immediately jumps out to me holly
is not just that relationship piece that
of course i'm looking at it through the
lens of my own relationships but um is
that real estate typically only goes up
anyway yes the market is hot right now
but you're not going to lose money if
you stay in your house your your your
house is secure your house is safe i
mean your your
real estate goes up typically so my
thought my gut is
no stay you know especially when you
said like i think i know like i think
that's not a good idea from the
relationship aspect you don't need to
you don't need to unless you i mean is
there is there some
financial burden that you didn't mention
do you have a lot of debt like what's
what's going on with your other finances
that makes you feel like you need to
sell it to to have that money
um i think the biggest
concern is that i am 40 and i only have
about 60 000 so far in retirement i've
been following the baby steps for the
past four years
cut up my credit cards i paid off 30 000
plus dollars in credit cards over the
past four years and i just paid off a 50
000 student loan in september congrats
congratulations that's huge
thank you um i went back as kind of a
non-traditional student or into my mba
in 2015
and went from earning around 40 000 a
year to now i make about 86 and change
amazing you are amazing
thank you so i feel like i'm on a really
good upward trajectory however now being
a mother there are daycare expenses
additional insurance costs things like
that so i'm on baby step two but i only
have about three thousand dollars left
of attorney's fees and that was um for a
child support related case
unfortunately that's still an ongoing
battle and kind of a variable
um but the other the other so that's
kind of where i am i feel like i'm in a
decent position but i'm a little bit
behind on retirement
i am eager and anxious to
begin um or to resume
the college savings fund for my daughter
and to get the three and three to six
months of um you know security put in
the bank for us
um so yeah that's kind of where so holly
here's been my experience over the last
24 months tell me if this rings true
with you at all
okay every
single
media outlet on the planet
i guess except for this show where
everybody seems to have kind of a still
pulse
is rattling every cage they have they're
banging every pot and every pan and
every gong and every drum letting you
know that you're not okay you're not
safe you're not filling the blank you're
not enough you should have been oh my
gosh
what you just rattled off to us is that
you got three thousand dollars you've
been
busting it
both in your
academic life in your professional life
in your personal life and then ta-da you
got a kid and hey let's figure this out
we're gonna keep going
you are walking
like as dave talks about the tortoise
and the hair you're the turtle you're
just getting up every day and you're
grinding it out you're working hard and
the next day you're working hard next
day working hard do you have a math
issue when it comes to retirement yeah
you're 40 i mean you got some money you
need to start socking away but you are
well on your way and what the every
system is telling us is you better do
something dump all of your money cash it
all out buy bitcoin do all this crazy
stuff
and then there's holly
getting up every day being disciplined
and doing it and doing it and doing it
i'm going to follow christy man unless
you tell me something catastrophic is
happening you've got to get out of this
house i don't like this house it's not
safe
i want your mother to be your
young child's grandmother i want you all
to love going up there for sunday
lunches and i want you to just keep
those negative voices telling you that
you're behind that you're not enough
that you screwed up keep those at bay
keep those out of your head turn the
stupid thing off and keep plug plugging
away step after step after step after
step and you're going to look up at 50
you're going to pay it off your house
you're going to have no debt left you're
going to settle this nonsense
legal stuff you're going to be debt-free
and you'll be able to cash flow college
you'll be able to save up for college
your retirement's going to start adding
up it's just doing the small things day
after day after day yeah and holly the
thing that stuck out to me when you were
telling me a little bit about your your
finances and your situation you said you
don't have much saved in retirement and
i'm 40 and i thought oh you're young
yeah you're a child
you're you're doing amazing you are like
a blink away from being debt-free you
are so stinking close to being debt-free
you're gonna get your three to six
months of emergency fund really quickly
after that
and then you're going to be adding to
your retirement and you'll be able to
speed that up and pick up once you don't
have these payments behind you you are
doing
absolutely fantastic i think there
sometimes when we get
so motivated and excited which is a good
thing in order to work the baby steps
and pay off our debt and so on we want
to fast forward it cut corners and you
don't need to you i mean like if someone
was in a desperate situation we'd say
yes sell the house to your point you're
not a desperate situation at all you're
actually in an awesome situation you're
doing really really great and and
despite the the hurdles that you've come
across the last few years you're
pursuing further education you've
increased your income by double
you've got a home a safe home for you
and your child you're just you're really
doing amazing and so if we're the only
people that are telling you this right
now let us be the people that are
telling you you're doing amazing you're
doing get some different friends you are
doing a great job you will get your
retirement in there when you get to that
baby step don't even worry about that
right now pay off that last bit of debt
work on your three to six months stay in
your home i think stability is even a
better thing when you've got other
things going on uh
you're doing great the answer to your
question is you're doing great and put
it this way it will cost you something
to move it'll cost you a piece of your
soul it will cost your relationship with
your mom it'll cost you relationship
with your child's grandparent it'll cost
you something not imaginary equity yeah
yeah that's good
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm chrissy wright john deloney and i
are taking your calls today triple eight
eight two five
five two two five if you have a question
about money relationships starting a
business life balance anything you wanna
talk about we are here for you we're
going to go to new york city new york
with pete hey pete how are you
how you guys doing good what's going on
i'm the proud owner of a tesla 3 a 2019
tesla 3 and i noticed that the trade-in
values for
used cars and in particular teslas are
very high almost as high as what i
bought it for
and uh i did a quick uh research kelly
blue book puts my trade in at around uh
forty nine thousand
cost of a new tesla three uh with zero
miles on it obviously uh is about 57k so
i was wondering uh should i go for it i
have 20 000 miles on the on the car i
have now or uh
realizing that i probably won't always
get a chance to lock in on such a high
trade-in or should i just go old school
like my dad would say and just drive it
into the ground which is what i had
planned to do before these uh trading
values went haywire what do you guys
think okay so i don't want to answer
this question in a vacuum outside the
context of your the rest of your
finances so let's talk about how the
rest of your finances are doing do you
have any debt
just my mortgage okay
and you have a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months
yep okay cool so i guess the thing that
sticks out to me we've got a lot of
calls like this and john you jump in on
this um the thing that's interesting is
people are asking questions should i do
this should i sell my house should i
trade in my tesla in this example
just because the opportunity is there
when really
outside of the opportunity or perceived
gain you
like the car that you have you like the
house that you have whatever so i guess
is it just purely because you could make
some good a good return on it
makes well it's not a good return
because i'm actually losing money
i'm sorry not a return what i mean is
like the trade the value that you're
getting back is more than you would
expect to get in this market that's what
i mean to say historic historically
trade and values for used cars are high
and it's high for tesla threes i read
that that's like the most in demand card
maybe i'm wrong but that's just what i
read so so you got 20 000 and then you
got 20 000 miles on it
yep so you're you're basically paying a
17 000 is that about right ten thousand
dollar what's that what you're going to
turn and go buy another tesla what's the
gap it's a difference the gap's about 9
000. okay so you're paying
if you had a hundred thousand miles on
this thing or for a tesla you'd have two
or three hundred thousand miles on it um
yep that makes sense it sounds like a
lot of headache
you're trading nine thousand dollars for
for 20 000 miles i mean a 2019 with 20
000 miles in my mind again i drive old
cars it feels feels brand new
um no i i agree what about this new
tesla so let's let's let's change the
the whole math problem here or not the
math problem psychology problem
what about this new tesla is more
exciting to you
than the current one that you have right
now
honestly like and i think you're kind of
getting at like what is the emotional
thing driving this if i'm reading your
question right and um i'm just asking
are you are you excited about the new
tesla
um you know it's not a whole lot better
than the one i have now it's just you
know there's a couple upgrades but but
it wouldn't be like a way better car it
would be close to parity just just newer
uh i guess what i'm really worried about
is or not worried but
am i going to miss this window where the
trade and values are as high as they are
and then i'll be kicking myself in five
years when i'm trading the car in for
you know fifteen thousand dollars when i
said you dummy why didn't you trade it
in when when you could have gotten a
better deal for it but you're talking
about a a two year difference here man
and twenty thousand miles i think i
think it's a perception thing yeah i
think it's
it's a perceived loss yes it's like this
i've gotta jump on this and it's that
fear of like what if i miss out to your
point but there's nothing that great
about the new car that you want need
whatever you like your car and so it's
more just it's more the opportunity that
seems shiny and i don't think there is a
cost to it not just the financial cost
but there's also the headache cost and i
think it sounds like you and your car
you're in a great situation i don't
think it's something you need to do yeah
so we we have a
there's an incredible book by daniel
kahneman called thank you fast thinking
slow and one of the things it talks
about is
we are so hyper sensitive to perceived
loss
even to the point that we will
go after perceived loss at the expense
of known gain right so yeah
i the hardest thing for anybody to do
right now is to just say i like my house
what i i know on paper imaginary
it's worth more
nobody's handed me cash yet so it feels
like it's worth more or my car or
whatever i guess i got to do something
now because i have to get this good deal
or three years from now i'm gonna be mad
i didn't get this great deal not ever
asking yourself dude do you like your
car and do you like your situation and
do you just want to throw nine thousand
dollars at a thing that might make you
feel better three or four or five years
from now that just seems bonkers yeah i
say i mean you're not gonna you're
debt-free do whatever you want man but
if it's me i'm gonna go that's cool yeah
i'm glad that my car has got high value
i'm gonna keep loving my car and then
i'm gonna go about my day yeah yeah and
the the thing i wanna highlight is
you're in a great position pete the fact
that you're even asking this question
you've done really well with your
finances you're debt-free you're in a
great spot
but at the same time it doesn't mean we
have to do something new just because
it's available just because you could
get a lot of money for your used car and
we again we keep using this example we
keep getting calls about this should i
sell my house because i could get a lot
for it it's like well do you want to
move no do you need to sell your house
no well and our friend kate coleman gets
that like hey
i just they called me and said would i
be interested in this promotion do you
want to do that work no no do you want
to have those hours no but it pays 30
000 more dollars
like think about your life we have this
it may never come again or they put me
in a position if i don't take this
promotion i'm never going to
man that's okay
the other thing i would add uh pete in
your scenario we didn't say this but i
want to make sure i say it the two
options you have is not trade in and go
to get a good amount um for your car now
to have a newer car
or
drive it into the ground there's like a
we could upgrade before you drive into
the ground it could just be hey i'm
going to drive this for about five years
and then your point maybe you traded in
for a little bit less but by that point
you've got so much more savings and
you've getting gotten great you know
great miles out of that car and then you
want to get a little bit newer car it
doesn't have to be these extremes and
when we think in extremes then it makes
it feels like it makes the decision so
much more emotionally heightened and so
much more like oh my gosh so much is in
the line you could just you could just
do that in like two or three years if
you want to but for everybody out there
listening wondering
should i sell my house or should i sell
my car because it's a good moment to do
those things that's the wrong question
the right question is do you need a new
car right do you want to and can you
afford to move into another house and
then you look backwards and say okay
what's the market for myself my sale
here right yeah this is um it doesn't
always apply in in these scenarios but
it makes me think one of the things i've
talked about at business boutique last
weekend and i've talked about in the
context of all of my teaching on life
balance which has been such a theme this
fall sometimes we just look at good
opportunities and we say should i do
that because it's good
but a good thing at the wrong time is
the wrong thing yeah a good thing at the
wrong time will stress you out a good
thing at the wrong time will you
actually put you in a bad position and
so just asking yourself not is this just
a good thing is this the right time for
that thing and uh and when you ask
yourself that you'll come up with a much
better answer whether that's with your
finances with your car with your home
with your business don't just ask
yourself is this opportunity good is
this the right opportunity
and is this the right opportunity now
and i love how you talked about the even
the science behind the perceived loss
because that drives so much of our
behavior there's a there's an incredible
study at
where
you come into a room and you have 50 one
dollar bills
and
you start laying them down one after the
other and i'm a stranger i sit down
and then i call it i say
um
good you you know you call good i put
down three dollars and then if i accept
the deal you take 97 i take three and
we're out of here
and what the research found is if i
perceived it to be unfair to it within a
certain degree i would say no and
scratch the whole deal rationally
speaking i would walk away with three
dollars more than when i sat down but
unless you put down 55 and i get 45 and
i'll be like
okay but if i felt like uh
it's this it's this perceived loss that
we're so obsessed about and we lose the
fact that dude i could just take 10
bucks and go chick-fil-a here and grab
some dinner that i didn't have before
yeah right so you got a great car you
got a great house
yes it's it's got some imaginary money
associated with it great are you happy
with your life right now yeah don't look
for these imaginary losses that haven't
happened yet that might happen in future
you're going to make yourself crazy in
the present that's good that's good
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm christy wright joining me is my good
friend fellow ramsay personality dr john
deloney and this is a very special
moment because
one of our own ramsay solutions team
members here in nashville tennessee matt
is on the debt free stage hey matt how's
it going
hey christy hey john how are you it's so
exciting this is huge okay so this is
really fun for us because you're on our
team and we get to hear your story and
so obviously
you work here on the team but we're
going to hear the debt-free journey
let's start by getting the basics how
much debt did you pay off uh eighty
thousand one hundred and ten dollars wow
and we're not supposed to ask this but i
gotta know how much money you make i'm
just kidding don't answer that just
kidding
hey don't tell everybody what your role
is on the team though what's your role
in the team uh i'm a developer on the
b2c
uh team cool one of those really smart
people that knows how to program things
and make things happen for you guys that
go to our website and things like that
okay how long did this eighty thousand
one hundred dollars take you 27 months
227 months how long have you been on the
team uh i started may 10th so just under
six months oh you're somewhat new yes
okay cool okay well then cool so when so
when you take us back to 27 months ago
this is before you were a team member
take us back to that moment and how you
got started on this whole journey
so i was uh dave ish for probably
not five ten years i mean dave always
says that the the hardest baby step was
baby step one i don't know i did it i
mean five six times at least
it's not that hard i just keep doing it
yeah i just kept doing it that's right
uh but in july 2019
uh
i met a girl i thought i was going to
get married that did not happen but
that event caused me to
to really have to reflect and like
what do i want to be true you know when
i get to this stage of my life the
meeting her the breakup uh the meeting
her okay like when i met her i was like
oh like if i marry this girl like what
things do i want to be true you know
that weren't true then which is a lot
you know so the one i decided to tackle
first was finances okay um and i decided
um
to really just submit to this program i
decided i am and not in fact smarter
than dave so
um
when i went
i decided you know i tried to do it
before and failed so i was like i'm
gonna get a coordinator so i actually
took fpu with a coordinator i was the
only one in his class shout out to mike
ford he's so awesome um
and
you know like having that the
accountability from the coordinator and
then the accountability with
uh some friends in my family like
those two things really
uh
really were the difference in the 27
months that's awesome well i'm really
impressed that you
when you decided to commit to it
you did something different in order to
have different results like going
through it with the class having a
coordinator having having different
people around you because a lot of
people they will attempt to do something
like pay off their debt multiple times
and when they don't it just it kills
their confidence that they can because i
tried that didn't work tried that didn't
work and you're like i didn't try that
didn't work i'm gonna do something
different so that it does work and you
did that which is awesome i didn't ask
this but um what kind of debt was it
um so it was
i owed my parents 1200 from them fixing
my car i owe i had about 10 000 credit
card debt
uh 20 on a car and the rest was student
loans okay so a little bit of everything
how old are you matt i am 33.
so this 27 months 80 thousand dollars
you hit the gas when you turn the corner
you said enough's enough's enough what
lit that fire
um you know i i'm an enneagram one so
like once i got convinced to do it and
once i had the accountability and the
structures in place you know i just i
just hit it and i also should say um
probably the most
tactical thing i did though was i really
just
leaned into god's calling
for me you know
the first was submitting to this program
uh and god really blessed that and then
i also
i had been i'd felt for a long time
probably at least a year probably that i
should increase my tithe from
tithing off my net to tithing off my
gross income
and i'm not a prosperity guy the only
thing
that i think god owes me when i read the
new testament is a butt kicking
so uh but i had felt called to do that
for a really long time and i finally did
it and i was really really nervous
um
but those two events together led to my
income going up 47 000 in six months wow
very cool uh just from that's all and
i'm like i'm good i mean i'm willing to
believe i'm good but i'm not that good
yeah yeah well there's some there's such
a principle in there and it can get into
you know people could have opposition
saying oh prosperity all that but i have
just found again and again and again
obedience precedes the blessing and it
wasn't about the amount of money
necessarily probably it was about the
obedience obedience to the plan and your
your words submit obedience to tithing
what you're just any whatever it is just
doing what god is asking you to do
god blesses obedience absolutely and
you're just such an example of that okay
so matt you have heard the debt-free
calls um you know people call in
what is the key for you and i know you
have an interesting story because 20 of
the months were not on this team six
seven of the months were on this team um
for for your seat and how you've walked
this out what do you think the key was
that helped you actually do this uh so i
mentioned the the tactical thing uh the
biggest strategic thing i think was
evaluating the my previous times that i
had failed
and really just knowing my why you know
ao always says that if your why doesn't
make you cry then the price of
commitment will and that for me that was
so true um that
like i knew why i was making sacrifices
i mean the car that i had that on i sold
it
and the one i replaced it with has had
probably three thousand dollars worth of
repairs at least
like you know one right after the other
and but i still kept going because i
knew
it was worth it though i still had the
why of why i had done it so i knew
i didn't like even though i was tempted
to just go buy another car
on payments i was like no that's not why
i sold the other one that's you know i'm
getting out of debt it matters yeah was
a member of our team i i i don't want
this to be lost on the listener anybody
watching this but especially on you look
around here man everybody stopped
working they come out here to cheer on
the brother
and as you've crossed this incredible
threshold and you head into whatever's
coming next for you
i want you to never forget
you're not alone in this deal and it's
incredible i i just reminded every day
we show up to work here with somebody
high five just says good job
you've got an army of people here walk
doing this crazy life thing together
with you
and um they got your back for whatever
comes next right yeah so good okay who
who else in this journey have been your
biggest cheerleaders uh so my parents
were a big help i uh
during covid i ended up staying over
there a lot because i was i work remote
i was at the time i was working remote
and i mean i would go like
days without talking to anybody in
person so i ended up over at my parents
a lot they also have an anxiety-written
dog that i needed to take care of
so i did that and then my buddy aaron
and his wife sarah are both
uh they were both my accountability
partners i want to be like both of them
somehow when i grow up um
and
you know
they were really sort of the tactical
like hey i really want to buy this and
they just said no no like you don't need
it no you don't need it i love it well
matt you're amazing and the work that
you do here at ramsey solutions is what
leads to the life change of so many
people that are listening to this show
right now and so we're so so grateful
you're on the team so grateful for you
to share your story and uh and gosh what
an amazing hard work that you paid off
eighty thousand dollars and 27 once
you're you're incredible no you know
matt normally when you say we have a
copy of the legacy journey and total
money makeover which i think you have
access to anything you want here as a
product benefit as a team member
all right matt
matt
from nashville tennessee here on our
debt-free stage as a member of ramsey
solutions paid off 80
110
in 27 months matt count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
i'm debt-free
[Applause]
i love it i love seeing the team in the
lobby oh my gosh it's so cool and how
cool that the last six months or so
as he paid it off was here on our team i
mean that's just
one of my favorite parts about matt's
example is he said i tried a few times i
was davish i tried to fail tried failed
and then i did something different do
something different do something
different doing the same thing over and
over again i just yell at my kid all the
time and they just keep doing the same
thing will you change
maybe you guys are listening right now
and you've tried this baby steps plan
you've tried the dave plan you're
daveish and it hasn't worked maybe
you sign up for a financial peace
university class maybe you sign up for
ramsay plus maybe you get an
accountability accountability group
maybe you put some things in place to
help you do the things you say you want
to do maybe you do something different
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright dr john delonia are
taking your calls answering your
questions got a question about
relationships
money
starting a business
or the million-dollar question how do
you balance it all
it's one of my favorite ones to answer
especially these days we are here for
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five answer that question's like 20
bucks you wrote a book on it didn't you
i have a book for you it's like 20 bucks
you know it cost a million dollars
well that's the question that everyone
loves to ask everyone loves to talk
about and here's the thing everyone has
a lot of feelings on this topic of
balance they have a lot of feelings on a
lot of things totally but despite their
hatred of the word
can't stop talking about it
you can't stop asking about it so yes
someone asked me in an interview
recently like yeah you just you just put
that on the cover the guilt-free guide
who i found so like sure did i'm an
enneagram eight i'm just gonna go right
into this
conflict i'm gonna reclaim it
redefine man
see what i did there redefining i know
it's a thing all right let's go to palm
beach florida with janice hey janice how
are you
hi christy i'm good how are you good
what's going on
well i'd love to ask the question about
balance but today i have a different
question hey it's free not even a
million dollars
yeah
well you guys are gonna think i'm joking
um but i found out over the weekend that
my father
bought a car for my 12 year old daughter
wow
planning
on
unveiling it on christmas as a gift for
her and he doesn't know that i know
about it and i
honestly am really upset and do not know
how to approach this
with him
that so sounds like something my dad
would do janice why would he buy
seriously why walk me through this i
want john delony to walk us through this
together janice yeah should my dad do
this potentially first of all can ask a
follow-up how did you find out
uh my mom told me oh okay all right all
right
this is your very good friend dr d okay
so why
why why did why did your dad this isn't
the first time he's done this what but
why did your dad buy a car for your 12
year old
okay so let me give you a little bit of
background information i know
my
dad had this older jeep that belonged to
his dad before he passed away and he
recently made about six months ago
approached me and said
that he wanted to give that jeep to my
daughter for you know when she was able
to drive and i was i said no we have a
plan with that you know we're gonna make
sure that she works and saves money and
we told her already that we're going to
match it you know we have a savings
account she asks to see it every once in
a while to see how much money is in it
you know all that sort of stuff and he
said well why you know why can't she
have achieved like well it's really old
jeeps aren't super safe and i think from
that he heard well it's old and jeeps
aren't safe so let me let me get a
different car
that's actually that's not what he heard
but go ahead i'll tell you what he heard
in a second
so you know and i told him we have a
plan we want to do this for her and um
yes but he
totally
ignored it which he does say how long
has he completely ignored your plan and
your boundaries probably for all of your
life
always yes
and so what he heard was oh a boundary
that's cute watch me go right through it
i am so here for this
for this answer janice i am on the edge
of my seat i know a friend who might
be curious can i ask you one one more
hard question
sure
what does he contribute to you and or
your daughter financially
uh nothing anymore i was a single mom
for the first five years of her life so
i did rely on my parents a little bit
with some help with day care and
insurance expenses okay um once i got
married my husband and i worked really
hard to pay off debt for about three
years but i think
my family saw us working really hard and
didn't quite understand it and thought
oh they must not have any money
so i think maybe he still thinks that
but as of right now he does not
contribute anything gotcha so um we
could do this one all day long this is
super fun for you um
here's the the way to cut through this
is always remember two things
secrets destroy relationships
and secrets are weapons for bullies
narcissists um people who are small that
are trying to feel bigger
and so the approach through this is
throw all the lights on and turn all the
music off call your dad and say i heard
you got my daughter my 12 year old a car
walk me through what you're thinking dad
and here's what you're gonna do that is
um punching a bully in the nose
i'm not gonna let you show up and then
put me on blast in front of my 12 year
old to make me the bad guy when i tell
you to take this gift that you got my 12
year old away
and so call it out and say did you do
this and let him the
stammer around and then he'll say you
need to save this and i'm just trying to
help out in just five years and he's
gonna weaponize how he's helped you in
the past
and make you the bad guy because he had
to step in and help you he's always got
to step in and help you and blah blah
blah
and
this is where this is gonna become
important you laid a boundary down when
he said i wanna get her the old jeep i
wanna fix it up and give it to you and
you said no we have a plan
well now he's calling your bluff on your
boundary and we get to see what you're
made of
okay this is where you're gonna have to
say something hard like if you bring a
car to my house i'm gonna have it towed
away
or you are not welcome at christmas if
you show up to my house with a car for
my 12 year old i love this advice so
much i want to ask one quick question of
janice as as john is giving you this
advice janice have you ever had similar
hard conversations do you have the habit
of calling your dad out on this stuff in
the past
yeah probably at least once a year and i
did have a follow-up question should i
bring my husband in on this conversation
with my dad or should i just leave it
between us for now
uh i
i think that six one way half dozen
another um i think you talked through
the decision with your husband if it's
me i'm gonna reach out to my parents
christian i've actually disagreed on
this we've had a lot of fun with that on
your show um i don't know that that's
necessary you can if you want him to
call your dad and say hey you're not we
have a plan my my your daughter my wife
told you that um but i'm stepping in
here saying there's not gonna be a car
brought to my house on christmas period
um and i'm have it towed away i don't
know that that's necessary
i think if you are as direct as john is
telling you to be which is absolutely
what it's going to take
i think you're dead i don't think you
need to invite her i don't i don't see a
reason why you need to i say this in
love because i've had these exact
conversations with my parents i mean
it's like we are so close and because
when you have a real close relationship
there can be a lack of respect for
boundaries that's right and it's like i
will be as direct as you i'm like we're
not doing that i don't know how else to
say it that is not happening
if you're willing to be that direct i
think you will get through but you can't
tiptoe around this janice like you've
gotta you've gotta say why did you do
this i will tow it away this is not
happening and you've gotta be that clear
and expensive i can't say are you
absolutely crazy
well
when you do that you are evoking emotion
and you're trying to
um i'm gonna contradict myself here
you're trying to hit him back and i just
said you're punching a bully in the nose
which is
you want to take the absolute most
dignified high road here because you're
dealing with a child and just say the
facts like you always say this just say
the facts there's no reason to say are
you crazy because it doesn't matter even
if he is it doesn't matter it's
irrelevant because that car is not
coming to your house on christmas and as
long as you cover that this car is not
coming to our house on christmas or it's
getting taken away it's going to get
towed and that would be embarrassing for
you
but like as long as you're that clear
then you don't have to have any of those
slams
like those jabs and
this part always sounds fun and
empowering when you talk to somebody
about boundaries and they'll walk away
be like yeah i'm gonna
make no mistake this will cost you it
will be hard
because i know most people who try
things like this garbage are immature
psychologically and spiritually he'll
throw a temper tantrum it will well then
i'm not doing anything and he's not
going to call you on your birthday it'll
be all kind of manipulative nonsense on
the back end of this deal
that's where your husband and your close
community of friends will really be you
know i always say that your friends or
your emergency fund for life that's when
you're gonna have to lean on folks
because you have a father figure who's
acting like a four-year-old right
yes and so when you understand the back
end of holding your boundaries is going
to cost you something whether it's
relational whether it is a pity party
whether it's actual money
um because he's supporting you in some
shape form or fashion which he's not
anymore then yeah hold your boundaries
hold your boundaries firm and um don't
look back yeah you got this janice good
luck
don't let him manipulate you
parents your child your christmas your
family your grown-up kids be grown-ups
support and love them i feel like we
could do a theme hour on boundary
stallone i feel like we i feel like this
needs more dignity and clouds sold 20
million books maybe for a different day
all right i want to thank producer james
child associate producer kelly daniel my
co-host dr john deloney and you america
for listening this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright author of the
new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance and i'm
joined today by my good friend dr john
deloney host of the dr john deloney show
author of the best-selling book
redefining anxiety and we are here for
you give us a call triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're taking
your calls about money as always but if
you wanna talk about relationships you
have a relationship question you have a
question about time management or work
or business or all of it yeah a boss
that you just can't handle anything and
let's be honest they're all related
anyway all related all the time you
don't have a work life and a home life
all your different areas of your life
affect each other work affects home home
effects works your relationships affects
your money of you know it goes in all
directions
and so we'd love to talk to you give you
some advice talk through it with you
help you see your options triple eight
eight two five five two two five john
one of the things that um i think is
really fun here as a as a team ramsey
solutions and um you know especially in
the busy fall season i feel like we're
kind of coming to the end of the fall
and the busy season we're always
planning ahead so i'm curious what are
you working on what are you excited
about what are you thinking for next
year what kind of things well he's going
to tell you
i will first say i haven't got to tell
you congratulations to be a number one
bestseller dude thanks that hit the big
old
numero uno yeah that's all that's fun
thank you so i turned in my manuscript
for a big book uh when does this come
out i know it's not like i'm like april
april okay and so a little
we're excited and starting the hole
getting ready to get that ball rolling
downhill now is it so does it launch for
pre-sale in april in february okay
gotcha but it will be a
kind of the
the
flag in this in the sand on how to
change your life and man just the the
nonsense and the about relationships and
mental health and all of it that we've
been just sold a bill of goods man and
here's how to get it back how was this
process different for you than uh
writing redefining anxiety um redefining
anxiety was more like a grad school
paper i mean for me it was like a
um this was more of something i've been
working on for about 10 years and just
happened to be here yeah and so yeah
and there's a team of people that help
make sure my i can get a little uh pop
off the mouth a little bit and they'll
say what does that actually mean and
i'll say i don't really know and so
there's a refining process here which is
great and there's editors here so i the
book will be much shorter than what i
submitted which is good because i talk
too much but um i'm looking forward to
it did you know that when i turned in
the manuscript for business boutique
well let me let me start over when i
wrote business boutique our team i was a
new author and our team really didn't
know if i would have enough words
oh
yes we have plenty we can all laugh
about that now in hindsight so my
instruction was to write until and i
quote the cows come home right until the
cows come up just keep right like they
were so concerned i wouldn't meet my
word count the minimum word count that
they needed was uh sixty or seventy
thousand words i turned in one hundred
and ten thousand yes
yes fun fact for those of you guys that
have read business boutique uh the
reason it is the size that it is is to
spread out all the words to make it
physically larger so it wouldn't be a
tomb of thickness that's exactly right
that's
basically what i turned entered in a lot
too so yeah yeah so we have a good
editing team it's a fun it's a fun
process though you write your you know
put your heart and soul into that and i
know it's going to help a lot of people
dave tells the story about
the
one of the way back in the day when he
was doing just financial peace
university that he had written the his
first book and it was the the
it was clear and simple and the woman
who who spoke the words over him that
have just stuck in his heart for years
finally a finance book i can understand
and that was the echo through
this whole writing process for me which
is
finally a mental health
and relationships book that i can
actually understand that's right that
99.9 of people can actually pick up and
it's not 800 pages and it's not full of
all of this complex neural that stuff's
important and i geek out on that what i
found is my friends don't and what they
do is they just stop reading yeah they
give up and this stuff's too important
now yeah we're all frazzled and cooked
and burned and we've got to make some
changes that is such a complex i mean
i'm sorry that's such a gift to take
complex ideas and put them in simple
language that people can understand um
i'm reading a lot of books right now in
seminary and the ones that i can
actually understand i'm so grateful for
versus the people that just write to
sound like smarty pants i'm like okay
you're super smart now i need a
dictionary to look up every other word i
get how smart you are could you please
explain it in a way learners
that's how they talk like when they're
at the movies
and
my daughter said something the other day
she used a word that was 111 syllables
and my wife and i looked at each other i
was like
we're raising nerds and she's like yeah
it's because that's what we are john
like so it's the way people talk but
it's not helpful yeah to most people's
time so it's anyway i'm excited to get
it out there and congratulations on your
book
that's gonna be so good all right let's
go to detroit with dawn hey dawn how are
you good in yourselves good what's going
on
um i consider myself baby step four
um do you consider yourself or you
actually are hey
well i consider myself baby step seven
but i am not mathematically there but
it's fun to
think about it
i have all my debt paid i have a six
month uh emergency fund
um but i have not been able to put 15
percent towards investment
because
my uh
elp we both came to agree and said i was
house poor so i sold the house
and moved into an apartment so i will
always have an apartment rent
so i want to try to increase my
investments because for 26 years they
were frozen
and in addition i don't know how much to
set aside for medical i usually have
seven to ten sometimes twelve thousand
dollars a year in medical
fees
okay payments
so you're just saying from a budget
standpoint how to set aside the money
for
your medical expenses yeah
right well i mean it sounds like the
good part is it sounds like this is not
a huge mystery you've got a range even
the range you just gave me seven to
twelve thousand i know that's a you know
you got some five thousand dollars in a
range there but at least gives you
something to work with and the good news
is that let's say for example you set
aside ten thousand dollars and you you
budgeted that out as you know whatever
roughly you know you wanted to do on a
monthly basis
and your medical bills next year in 2022
came in at 15 000.
you have an emergency fund for that
reason if there were if there's
something above and beyond what you
expected or anticipated or budgeted for
especially when we're talking about
medical here that is exactly what that's
for so i think you're i think you're in
a better position than you might feel
like um dawn for for
you know having that having that money
there and do you have a health savings
account that you can keep this money in
yes i do now i did not have yeah that's
an important vehicle for you because it
will
it will be there in the years when you
only have five thousand dollars and it
will
it will grow so the years you have the
ten thousand dollars or the twelve
thousand dollars it will it will roll
over year after year which is fantastic
what's your health challenges that are
ongoing that that at that cost
i have autoimmune connective tissue
disease the central nervous system
that's painful painful painful huh
at times uh but just recently i'm in um
early stages of heart failure oh i'm so
sorry dawn so sorry well we'll be
thinking about and praying about it um
praying for you but yeah just be
intentional about those costs and put
that money away
um and it's
hard hard money to put away do it every
month put it into hsa and we'll roll
over for you
and um we'll be praying for you you've
done you've done a good job so far don
you're doing great this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 dollars a
month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
last 18 months have been a lot a lot of
worry a lot of wondering what would
happen next and maybe that's how you
feel about your money too
tired stuck stretch thin
but it doesn't have to be that way you
just need a plan because a plan gives
you confidence even when everything else
seems out of control and that plan is
financial peace university
this class will teach you everything you
need to know to save money pay off debt
and build wealth for the future you can
stream the lessons on your own or get
the support or get support by going
through the class with others then
you'll put that plan into practice with
the premium version of our every dollar
budgeting app by syncing your bank to
your budget you can easily track your
spending and see where your money goes
you get all this only with a ramsey plus
membership
you don't have to stay exhausted and
overwhelmed you can win with money to
start your free trial of ramsay plus
text trial to 33789 that's trial to
33789
all right today's blinds.com question of
the day find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering you
get free samples free shipping with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even
more use promo code ramsay to get the
best deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from trina in
california
trina says my husband and i have four
children ranging in age from seven to
fifteen
we live in a three bedroom two two-bath
home so the kids share two bedrooms and
a small bathroom
my oldest daughter has anxiety disorder
and insomnia so she struggles with
having to share a room it's also hard on
her siblings to share a room with her
she's constantly looking at bigger homes
for sale in our town and when we tell
her we're not moving she begs us to let
her move in with her best friend or
grandparents she can have a room of her
own
are we being selfish because we chose a
smaller house that we can afford my
therapist suggested we consider moving
into a bigger house with a 30-year
mortgage just to give her that space for
the next three years and then downsize
again when she is on her own
so to answer your question here are we
being selfish because we are living in a
home the size of which we can afford the
answer is no
good for you
um i think we have a culture christie
where people have
buy caught gigantic cars they can't
afford and gigantic homes they can't
afford so everyone's got a bathroom
everyone's got a room everyone's got a
yard everyone's got a pony and a
whatever
so no
you're not being selfish if you're
living a smaller house that you can
afford
if you try to if you the reality is you
live in a smaller home and you have a
lot of people people are sharing rooms
then you have to be hyper intentional
about connectivity about roles about how
who is not here's the rules of our house
but here's why you matter here and kids
feel a desperate need for connection and
they feel a desperate need for purpose
and if you just plop a 12 year old in a
15 year old's room and say y'all figure
it out yeah dude we're not going to
figure that out so the easiest thing
here is to run is to punt this down the
road let's take on another couple
hundred thousand dollars in mortgage
debt so that we can what i'm telling you
this won't solve the problem yeah right
you won't solve the problem you'll have
a 15 year old who disappears for three
years and then moves out you will not
have healed or supported or helped your
daughter you may have quieted the chaos
for a minute my guess is you won't um
when kids have anxiety when they've got
insomnia when they've got ocd when
they've got adhd
i always want parents and this is myself
included here
understand most of the time your kids
bodies aren't broken or disordered those
that anxiety that insomnia that is your
body saying i'm not safe there's
something going on here i'm not okay
it's not because there's somebody
sharing my room with me most of the time
it is something bigger than that so i
want to look at those challenges not as
things to run from but as let's get in
try to figure out what your body's
trying to tell you here yeah and those
are hard and those are messy
and i'll tell you if your therapist is
telling you yeah you know what you
should
do put your family at risk in a
situation financially that you can't
afford to placate a 15 year old you may
need to get a new therapist right that's
a that's a tough situation they put you
in what do you think
yeah i guess it just for me one of the
hardest parts about this it's not just
about the house or about the money i
totally agree with you obviously you you
need to live in house you can afford and
and figure out what's really going on
that's probably not the room i think one
of the hard things and i'm curious your
thoughts on this when it comes to
parenting and i still consider myself
pretty new at this because my oldest is
six so i have been in the parenting game
for six years i just have three kids
under age sex
the hard thing is when they have
different needs
not just that they're wired different
they have different personalities but
they have different needs
um it feels unfair to have different
expectations of them like that i would
expect of carter that he behaves
differently than my middle son conley
gotcha not just because their age but
because of their capacity right and so
how do you handle that where as the mom
as the parent as the dad you're going
okay we've got four kids one has some
things that she struggles with
and so and so how do you accommodate
that and make that child feel safe
while also not making it
quote unquote unfair or whatever with
the other kids in the household where
it's like okay we don't want to walk on
eggshells around this child because we
don't want to ignore these children and
do you see what i'm saying i don't feel
great i don't feel like i'm asking
anyone
perfectly but there's other kids
involved in this equation and how do you
help everybody when their needs are
different and their struggles are
different so the demon of
mental health challenges or more
specifically the demon of everybody's
body reacts differently to things
some people respond to chaos by getting
really loud some kids respond to chaos
by
trying to disappear become as small as
possible
the challenge here is you can't see it
and what i mean by that is my son is 11
and he's humongous i will ask him to go
grab uh hey we go grab that thing for me
while i'm in the middle of cooking
something because he's tall and he can
go get that right i won't ask my
five-year-old little little girl she's
very short i'm not gonna ask her to do
that that's beyond her capacity
similarly i want all my kids to get in
the car and go to target with me right
now even though she's exhausted he's
been running a track meet and he played
a baseball game and so i i tend to
moralize and and make issues of
character things i can't see
and so every kid's got different needs
and it may be that for a 15 year old who
is brain is saying we're not okay right
now i can't even go to sleep at night
because i'm scared something's not right
that tells me there's chaos in that home
that tells me there's third rails in
that home and that tells me that hey you
know what i really love i love our whole
family getting together for dinner that
might be the only hour of the day that
my 15 year old has time
to herself and so for this season i'm
going to concede that but you're going
to go on a walk with one of us with mom
or dad and that means mom or dad we're
not going to be able to watch our
favorite show every night of the week so
or we have to put our phones down and
fill in the blank right
it's about re-examining the entire
picture but no i think you're exactly
right as a parent i want all my kids to
do what i say and the way i say it
because i have this picture of going to
the hardware store today i just got to
know that man she's got to go to sleep
right now yeah and he has asked can i
just have some time by myself and i'm
not going to do that to him yeah and
those sometimes those are issues of
character we're all going to store and
so when we're going i need to be
respectful
most of the time that is something
that's exceeding their capacity and as a
parent i got to change my picture of
what that's going to look like yeah i
think that's so powerful and and
something we have to practice on a
regular basis
you let go of this picture of how you
thought it was going to be and one of
the things i learned from david thomas
who has written multiple books and he
i've had him on the christy great show
he's so smart but he's he he talks about
be okay with letting go of that picture
for this season it doesn't mean forever
but maybe in this season we're going to
let this child off the hook and they're
not going to have family dinners and
they're going to eat in their room or
eat on their own because they just need
some peace and quiet to themselves in
this season but see as a parent you
think like we're never going to eat as a
family again it becomes these extremes
in this season you can let go of your
expectations and the way that david
thomas said it which i love how he
talked about this he said for a better
outcome you can force it and everyone's
miserable and anxious and not sleeping
or you can say okay what what is needed
maybe we divide up sometimes matt and i
will split up the kids even though i
want everybody together but we'll split
them up for a better outcome saturday
you're gonna take two i'm gonna take one
or vice versa and i just love that it's
it's a hard
step to take to say i'm going to let go
of what i wanted things to be
but if it's for a better outcome then
it's amazing because it really is that
act of love of saying this is going to
lead to better results for everybody
yeah so think think this this guide to
me
if i
get
to a conversation with my wife and i win
and she loses we both lose that's right
when i get into a
piss and match with my kids
and i win and they lose we all lost yep
and so the goal is how can i even have
to make hard decisions hold my kids
accountable get them to do things they
didn't want to do
it's because of this outcome yeah and
they've got to know where we're headed
here yeah and i've got to be flexible in
that season yeah that's good being
willing to let go of that that's good
that was a good good question great
question but i'm glad we talked about it
because i know a lot of people probably
can relate to being in something similar
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken then create a free profile and let
their technology do the hard work by
finding and sending you jobs that are a
great fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
listen
do not let your valuable time pass you
by your time is like your money once
it's gone
it's gone and if you try to balance it
all you can feel overwhelmed and at
times you end up pushing your goals and
yourself to the sidelines
putting your plans on paper is the key
to accomplishing anything in life
and i've got just the thing to help you
do that my 2022 goal planner is
here
and here's the thing you need to get
these before they sell out because trust
me they sell out every single year and
by the way they sell out earlier every
year
people love this planner so much because
it really helps you focus on what's
important to you your spirit mind body
relationships and resources we've got
monthly weekly and daily calendar
sections that you love but there's also
monthly teaching you've got content
every single month like reading a book
on a particular theme to help you grow
in that area of your life then you've
got action plans which are tools and
templates to help you put that teaching
into practice you've got guided
journaling to help you reflect on these
things
and even month in review so that you're
reflecting on the last month before you
dive into your goals for the next month
it is incredibly strategic to help you
stick with your goals and even assess
them and reassess them throughout the
year as your life and seasons change
because we know that they will
if you're ready
to crush your new year's goals whether
it's spiritual growth personal life
money or work or anything this planner
will help you get there so get your 2022
gold planner today in our online store
at ramseysolutions.com
and i promise you when they sell out
they're gone no we won't reorder i'm
sorry they're dated and so once they're
gone they're gone if you want to get
this as a christmas gift go ahead and
get it
the feedback has been awesome the
reviews are awesome and and people love
using them it not only helps you plan
your year it helps you put on paper on
purpose what you want your year to look
like which is a powerful step and
actually making that happen that's
ramseysolutions.com you can get your
2022 goal planner today okay let me ask
you this all right i need some help okay
huh this is me coming clean on the
ramsay show
this should be good million people this
should be good so
one of the things i struggle with most
in the world on 95 of my days i have a
note card with me that just have here's
what i've got to do today right i want
to make sure i do today well
i had a conversation this weekend i'm
working with a new doctor and we went
over everything from genetic testing to
i mean everything this guy knows me real
well and he's like you have a problem
with sweets don't you and i was like oh
my gosh did you know that right so he
knows everything are you reading my mind
yeah no he's just reading my my dna
i struggle with
setting up a plan like this
the day-to-day linking to a series of
outcomes that i'm looking forward to
um down the road whether it's a month in
advance two months in advance four
months in advance my philosophy has
always been i'm just gonna make sure i
work out today and tomorrow takes care
of itself yeah and the older i'm getting
the more i realize that's not always
true it will i'll end up somewhere but
it's often far from where i the picture
i had in my head of where i've could
have been yeah
so
how this thing
i don't know much about journals i've
bought a few in the past and they've got
like 11 ribbons in them and they're
supposed to go this back for
this thing sells out whenever they
announce it to this to our staff people
it's like
dave's just throwing cash at people it's
like people are screaming like ah it's
like it's like a
metallica concert when they announced
the the planners are out
what is the magic sauce number one that
makes this planner so good and number
two
give me
coach me okay forget the first question
we all know it's good help me
um
what would you tell somebody who
struggles with connecting the dots long
term
because the reality is i'm kind of just
stumbled through life
does that make sense yes yes i think
you're being
i think you're being a little either
humble or underestimating how much hard
work you've actually done that has led
to you no i've done a ton of hard work
being right here you didn't just wake up
here no i've done a ton of hard work but
it's all like
let's have a good tuesday and we'll get
i need some
a tip or two that's gonna help me get
from a to b okay here here's a link my
daily practices with goals so so
let me tell you one of the things that i
think is the magic of the planner and
and it's not a personality style and
it's not it so one of the things that
many women experience and this one this
book this planner is not just for women
though it's highly feminine looking it
has hot pink on it so probably most men
are not gonna buy but it's a great gift
for their wife but here's what i think
is is magical about it
so many women
feel this responsibility either spoken
or unspoken to be
cruise director of the universe
they are orchestrating all the pieces of
all the people all the time
that's a lot to manage so this planner
helps you manage that
but here's the power of it it helps you
consider yourself in that game
it helps you consider yourself in your
week it helps you consider yourself
in your day like how are you taking care
of yourself this week what are you doing
towards your goals this week what do you
what do you want your week to look like
and it's not a selfish message of like
ah bulldoze everybody or else you know
it's not that it's just like hey in the
grand scheme of the 400 things you've
got to do why don't we consider
ourselves how can you grow and take care
of your mind how can you grow in your
faith how can you take care of your body
but you know journal questions for
reflection just the simple practice of
pausing and saying hey how do i feel
about that
or how am i doing today before i pile on
the pressure of my to-do list whether
it's in a planner or on a sticky note or
a napkin yeah so many people all i think
all people do this but i i work with a
lot of women so a lot of my my products
are directed at women
they wake up they pour the coffee and
they just run as hard as they can then
they collapse and they collapse and they
they never even consider
how am i doing
what are my priorities for the day we
just react to the world around us and i
think that there's something very
powerful in getting in the rhythm where
you consider yourself in your own life
so such a simple concept but we don't do
it the reverse engineering of that for
those who
are
singularly focused on their life is
where do you plug into the world around
you right if you've got kids at home how
are you participating in their life if
you have a spouse at home how are you
participating in his or her life right
how are you making your household
um a better place a more hospitable
place a safe required or whatever place
yeah right so it's the opposite of that
but it's still the same well and it's
there's just certain while balance looks
different for everyone and goals look
different for everyone and even how you
plan if you're a planner on your phone
or planner paper everybody's different
that's totally fine but there and i
write about this in my book but there
are certain ingredients
to living
a balanced life there are certain
ingredients that that are good to have
in your life regardless of who you are
male or female any personality style
doesn't matter what kind of planner you
are
having time alone having key
relationships so even in in the weekly
planner of the the 2020 goal blender
there's a spot what am i doing for
myself this week what am i doing for my
family this week and what am i doing for
my dream this week your dream could be
your career or a project or a hobby or
your business so it's just remembering
hey these are things that each week not
every day we're not going to do them all
every day but each week hey if i haven't
done anything to take care of myself in
a week we need to check on that
self-care is not a pedicure or a spa day
once a year on christmas or your
birthday this is like brushing your
teeth it's a daily practice how are you
taking care of yourself on a regular
basis and so it's just those reminders
what am i grateful for it just gets you
in rhythms of of paying attention to
these different ingredients that that
create a
balanced life it's not all perfect and
it's not a formula but man when you have
a tool in front of you that just reminds
you of what's important to you it helps
you actually pay attention to it spend
time on it so knowing kristen and not
missing because you're telling me
i have to be intentional and make
choices
i like your napkins or your sticky note
system though i think that works great
yeah but it provides for a really
rudderless life it's fun but as my wife
reminds me there's a whole team of
people cleaning up the world behind you
john as you just are like ah what if we
try this you know what i mean or oh that
sounds fun i'm going to the gym it's
like well cool i will make sure the kids
have food right so it's it's a it's
exactly the opposite of
what some focus on which my life's about
everybody else and i am silent and
invisible in this life
versus the other side of it and again
it's a balance of yeah of both having
both in your life well i think the key
that i think people need to remember is
the tools that we create for you all
whether that is the every dollar budget
every dollar budgeting app or um ramsay
plus where you've got your course to
take your financial piece university
classes or john's book on redefining
anxiety or the 2022 goal planner these
are tools
to help you be the person you want to be
to create the life that you want to lead
to help you do what you say you want to
do
the the tool in itself is not valuable
those planners sitting in a warehouse
it's not valuable it's when you use that
to do what's important to you to spend
your time on what's important to you to
think about what do i want this year to
look like what do i want this month to
look like what do i want my budget to
look like how do i want to get out of
debt you know the plan is the path for
you to get to where you want to be
that's the reason people get out of debt
and it works so it's just it's the tool
you but you're the one that makes it
work uh that means i gotta do it
i see what you're saying here
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
romans 15 4 says for everything that was
written in the past was written to teach
us so that through the endurance taught
in the scriptures and the encouragement
they provide we might have hope romans
15 4.
martin luther king jr said intelligence
plus character that is the goal of true
education
all right we're going to go to new haven
connecticut with miguel hey miguel how
are you
good thank you how are you great what's
going on
thank you for taking my call sure uh
so i am
about to be 37 years old and uh
i'm finding myself in a pretty
overwhelming situation
uh i've got
about five hundred thousand dollars in
debt that has uh
accumulated it comes a it's a mix of irs
debt
uh student loans credit cards and auto
loan
and uh
i'm making 87 000 a year
on my
income and
about 17.50 a month on disability
so i'm finding myself in a situation now
where
it's all kind of
falling on my lap uh i just put together
my very first budget at 36 years old
using the every dollar app and i'm
coming up short
um
i'm not really sure where to go from
here so
i looked into bankruptcy chapter 7
chapter 13
um
and i got off the phone with a law
agency
earlier today they said that i would
probably qualify for chapter 13
but my income i guess is too high
for chapter seven
so i'm just kind of looking for some
guidance uh looking to see what my best
option would be
uh where i could get some
free advice uh if there's any
um
see where to go from here yeah i'm so
sorry
i can hear that in your voice yeah yeah
are you are you married have kids
overwhelming yeah uh so i have one child
um i'm divorced
and uh i've been through two separations
which have you know they've kind of led
me to this situation financially
um
so yeah i got a little bit on my plate
well yeah what do you what do you do for
a living
i am a nurse practitioner okay awesome
so currently i'm in a residency program
and they're only paying 87 000 a year
because i'm in a learning phase this is
a one-year program
after this if i decide to stay at the va
i'll go up to about
and 110 thousand
uh if i decide to go outside of the va
i will make more money but in the end
i'll lose you know retirement benefits
and
and you know free health care for life
everything that comes with being a
federal employee so that's another
question whether i should continue to
work at the va and bank on those
benefits
or you know seek employment elsewhere
and try to make as much money as fast as
i can
so what i would tell you is um you're
drowning right and you know that right
yes
um
here's here's the analogy that might not
be perfect but the analogy you just gave
me is i want to stay in the water
because i've got this life raft here
versus i'm going to start swimming to
shore and i'm going to get out of the
water completely
and what feels safe long term eventually
if you will
may ultimately sink you because you're
you don't have enough money here this
makes me happy that you're in a one-year
program okay because you're gonna at
least double your salary and absolutely
you're gonna get out of the va and go
out to the open market and work
and you're gonna be able to
being a nurse practitioner man you're
gonna be able to make a great salary
and you're gonna have to just start
slowly grinding this thing away and you
feel like you're 100 years old you're
not you're absolutely not
um
what uh you said you got disability
what's your disability from are you a
veteran
i am okay from my time overseas awesome
um
so you've got disability on top of your
87
uh correct
yes uh total
growth income
is 108.
okay all right great so
the chances of you coming out of here
and getting 160 or 170
what's that what's what's the
feasibility in your market
uh
i mean if i were to take travel
contracts like a local tenant position
yep i can probably get that there would
be you know multiple short-term
contracts which i've done as an rn
uh to make ends meet you know with the
kovit crisis there you go
um i'd probably do the same thing as a
nurse practitioner
so what i want you to step back and look
and say okay 37 i'm going to be 38 when
i'm out of this program here
if i put myself on a four and a half or
five year plan
and i worked backwards
what kind of contracts would i have to
take over the four and a half to five
years and will you be tired absolutely
you're gonna be exhausted
but what would it look like to pay this
debt off
settle some of this with the irs if you
can settle some of this with your credit
card company if you can you can't settle
those student loans those are just
weights you're going to have to tread
water with
what would it look like
what would i have to earn to be able to
reverse engineer this and my guess is at
150 160 175 000
this becomes a lot more surmountable
with if you've got a plan you're
experiencing christine's beginning of
this you're experiencing miguel with so
many folks and whether it's 500 000 or
50 000
is that initial shock when you see a
budget and you think oh no this is
forever and i want you to know it's not
but it's a matter of these baby steps as
you walk and and walk and you've got a
pacifier with the feds and you're going
to have to let that go
and you're going to have to work like
you thought you were busy when you were
younger in the ser you're going to have
to work like you haven't worked
but man at that salary at that level
you've got a big shovel you'll be able
to dig out of this quicker than you
think and just and the key to this is
while while you're making good money and
you've put in the work to do this
residency and all those things it's
going to be really tempting to be like
well
i deserve xyz you've got to live on
nothing yeah the the more you live on
nothing rice and beans means the rice i
mean you get creative with every
possible thing that you can to keep your
expenses to an absolute minimum
for a season the more you can live on
nothing and get that income up like
we're talking about the faster you're
out of debt and so you absolutely can do
this and one of the things that um
i want to make sure that we give you
miguel if you'll stay on the line i'll
have kevin
kelly give you a membership a year
membership to ramsey plus which it has
our class in there called financial
peace university and you watch these
lessons and here's what's gonna be so
key it's not only going to show you how
to get out of debt it's going to keep
you motivated on the journey there's an
incredible community in there as well
and you can connect with those people
you can get inspiration get
encouragement get teaching you'll also
have that budgeting app that we're
talking about which will sync with your
bank so watch those lessons and do
exactly like john said we've got to get
the income up to be able to get out of
this mess but you can do it and once you
can see the plan then you'll see how you
can do it so can i tell you this miguel
we just had a couple in a previous hour
on today's show do a debt-free screen
and
they paid off 500 thousand dollars
oh man and what they say they got they
got after it one day they got after it
in in five years yes and right after he
was diagnosed he was diagnosed with um
with a parkinson's parkinson's
and so i'm gonna tell you i just had
somebody stand in front of us on the
debt-free stage and they did it okay
here's another thing i want you to
remember um tell me about your little
one
uh she's nine years old nine years old
dan she loves this thing that's awesome
so listen to me
this stops with you
is because in five years
how you said she's nine years old
she's nine nine years old right in five
years she's gonna be 14.
and she's gonna have a debt-free dad who
walks about seven inches taller than he
is right now
and she's gonna get to have a ringside
seat to sacrifice to hard work
to hey we don't have the money to go to
disneyland so we're going camping
we're gonna sorry we're going fishing
we're gonna figure this stuff out we're
going to hang out with uncle so-and-so
and aunt so-and-so and they live in this
crazy town and she's going to have a
ringside seat to adventure and sacrifice
and she's going to get to watch her
family tree change
while she's in it
and it's because your sacrifice is not
going to go unnoticed so brother you're
about to change your family tree and
your daughter's never going to
experience this and your why goes way
past this scary moment right now
your legacy her legacy and her kids
legacy brother so congratulations and
you call us back when you're debt-free
and you're going to do that debt-free
scream on this stage absolutely with us
and we're going to celebrate you because
you're going to do it and i can't wait
to watch you do it going to be awesome
thanks for calling miguel
all right i want to thank producer james
child associate producer kelly daniel my
co-host dr john deloney and you america
for listing in this has been fun this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you